my name is Brenton Bostick my talk is
titled finding bugs in the Wolfram
language in this talk I will present a
new tool for finding bugs in the Wolfram
language I will demonstrate finding bugs
in notebook code and also finding bugs
and dot M code and other editors and
ID's and ways to automatically fix
issues when they're found
all right so welcome today today I well
every day I'm Brenton Bostick
I'm with Wolfram and today I'm gonna be
talking about finding bugs in the
Wolfram language I assume maybe some
people have learned about parsing
Wolfram language earlier this will be a
continuation in the same vein as that oh
good I can okay today's outline that
will be motivating why you would want to
find bugs in the Wolfram language may
not spend much time on that I'm going to
quiz people and then show the software
that I've been developing and then the
software that a the team that we've
created has been developing and then
show it and for the front end and then
showing its application and even other
editors and ID's so why would you want
to preemptively find bugs a good
argument is that it is more expensive to
find them the hard way and just a list
of infamous software failures that may
hit too close to home for people yeah so
can you spot the problem in this code
right here there's a straight comma yeah
okay cool can you spot the problem in
this code right here there are four
underscores okay can you spot the
problem in this code right here there's
an extra minus sign right there can you
spot the problem right here Linux isn't
an actual value for dollar operating
system people those were all real direct
derived I should say I'm not actually
attacking anyone specific those a the
function names have been changed to
protect the innocent
but
those yeah but those those illustrate
the common types of problems that people
run into the moral story is well from
syntax is complicated that seems to be a
theme with what I'm talking about today
there are a lot of operators in Wolfram
language unintuitive purse sentences but
something new implicit times is its own
beast which leads to missing comments
and missing semicolons all being
completely valid syntax and hard to
detect so the answer for finding these
types of problems is static analysis of
being able to analyze code before
actually evaluating it how would you do
that you might ask well and Wolfram
language the answer would best be used
the pattern matcher and so with parsing
code for example if you wanted to
process and find out how many integers
and symbols you might have in your code
you know it's very easy to do this kind
of thing but you didn't actually run
that code at all it's just represented
symbolically without having been
evaluated however static analysis is
also difficult for Wolfram language
because Wolfram language is very dynamic
and it is weakly typed you can create
symbols willy-nilly and it's hard to
know if you've missed a need statement
somewhere and implicit times leads to
things like this missing semicolons that
could go decades without being detected
in your code
I know I've written something like that
I don't know if any of you have but I
definitely have and operator forms are
now valid syntax so might be a cool
thing to show off and new features but
drives people implementing static
analyzers crazy because this is now
completely valid syntax also so yeah
just makes it ensures job security I
suppose as a way of looking at it but so
runtime checking is also difficult but
it's not going to be discussed here the
property of returning unev alyou ated i
will refrain from judgment calls on that
but the issue being I'm applying I'm
calling missing as if it were the head
of a function you know like so very hard
to talk about statically you tend to
only run it you see these things at
runtime
or you might not because you might just
mask over that whole thing and it's
actually very hard to see but will not
be talking about runtime checking here
so what I will be showing is the lint
Pacolet and you can see here given a
string lint string is going to be the
workhorse function and lint stirring
report makes things look the results
look nicer but the things that come out
are lint objects and it's nicely
formatted here and you can see for
example a one to one problem that are
found in this code is that both branches
of if are the same and the assumption
being that's not what you intended if
that's what you intended then I mean you
don't need to be using the lint or that
I guess but for people that don't want
to have their break but people have
written it that way and I so these are
just merely suggestions for what you
would want to be doing but you may not
want to have that in your code and so
yeah for spanning multiple lines you
might nicely you know nice formatted
stuff you can obviously let files the
same way there's a collapse file that
I've just been using as an example that
does have intentional errors in it you
know found three problems so what are
they there's actually a missing equals
you know between the in the you know
message setting the message yeah
unexpected because then you know why
would you have a multiplication at top
level but then also you have a span at
the end of the line which you probably
meant to be as just a single semicolon
so scroll over yeah and so obviously you
want to be able to jump there to your
code and so if you set things up
correctly you can get results so that
you can go and jump I don't know if
people can see the cursor blinking but
it just jumped over to where the problem
is so you can just quickly like change
that if you wanted to the cursor jumped
back up there so these are not pre-baked
examples so but yeah so you can change
that if you want
other reporting system is for implicit
times because yeah we mean to use
implicit times a lot more than
accidentally and but it's still a
problem and so there are not reports but
you get should be easy to actually
annotate where they are actually
occurring and so as a way of formatting
files I think you know underlining them
with kinds of showing where the exes are
and implicit times you may or may not
have meant to do that in your file so
you know just showing you what they are
is as possible so okay so the output is
also possible to get on the command line
like you see and compilers like clang
and GCC to be nicely colored and showing
you where you where they are this might
be more appropriate for some workflows
that people have so that's very nice
right and so the team the code
assistance team that has been assembled
recently has been spending a lot of time
on this feature of making all of this
nice reporting integrate better with the
front end and turn some stuff on so
here's an example where there's a
straight comma at the end of that input
cell there and so if you just evaluate
this well in the presentation that's
kind of funky looking but you get a
little guy saying you have an extra
comma there and if you click on the
little opener you have the option of
deleting that comma and look you know
it's magical and now your codes fixed to
to sign huh well no implicit
multiplication isn't a warning in and of
itself you have to run the separate
thing just to get implicit because it's
not I mean yeah you made you intend it
you meant it 90% of the time maybe you
know so yeah I mean it's its own thing
so you know here you have an unexpected
underscore the front end does a good job
of actually spacing there so that's
actually not such a good I mean you
still might miss that I mean I might
miss that but you probably you still
probably didn't mean to have that there
so let's fix that
similarly linux you probably meant to
say unix so magically fix that and cool
all of our code is but it has caught so
many that's specific you mean the linux
people love people love thinking that it
is I mean it needs it serves a purpose
though yeah I mean that's it that's
completely ad-hoc yeah yeah I mean like
well yeah I mean it's just you know you
know you write the pattern if you're
inside of a switch and you see you know
the first thing is dollar operating
system and then you see if any of them
are our Linux you know that's the
pattern and you know you go from there
and so I mean it's very ad hoc but like
useful sorry no there's only the three
no no or four I should say iOS is not to
denigrate iOS I meant for yes
yeah and yeah yeah well I mean okay
maybe it did a great Android yeah maybe
five yeah Larry well if you meant that
as a difference between Linux and UNIX I
mean these are now bugs I don't know
yeah I know I mean it's like it's just I
will say I mean it's very well it's only
the three I don't know I don't know it's
a heart yeah a dollar operating system
is four or five hard-coded values yes no
no it's all no no but if it's if we ever
update I will have plenty of lead time
to fix the lint er yes yeah yeah no no
no no no I mean it it's a trade-off and
I'm willing to take that work upon
myself to update it were op dollar
operating systems ever change so some
more interesting stuff from another
developer Timothy so we might have give
it a second
missing mismatched brackets in your code
that at first glance you might not know
how to fix and so we've spent a lot of
time training machine learning systems
to be able to respond with a certain
confidence whether or not you should add
or delete brackets in various locations
in the code and so with 99% confidence
we're supposed to have a bracket you
know after the with square bracket so I
would be confident with making that
change I think would be the correct
thing to do and then so similarly here
you can see with 98% confidence you
probably want to insert a bracket there
for example and then some some smaller
examples to show with 99% confidence you
probably want to delete that parentheses
it's already colored in the front end
but on principle you probably want to
delete that parenthesis
and then similarly with 65% confidence
not as confident you know you want to
add the association ending bracket there
so I think this is an interesting
application because it'll it'll show it
shows the two different complementary
complementary methods that we're using
where you might say that this is the
stuff I was showing before is more
rule-based and this is obviously machine
learning based but they can complement
each other and they you know they are
not fighting because my linting stuff
with parsing it would know that you have
a missing bracket because it wouldn't
you know be it would have parsing errors
but it's not gonna make any attempt at
fixing them figuring out where they are
and so machine learning can come in and
like fill that gap and just make a
better user experience all around so I
think that's just nothing but a complete
win for for people developing code right
so that's the front end I also want to
show some really cool stuff for other
editors and I tes
what we've been spending a lot of time
on is I don't know if people are
familiar or not with the language server
protocol but it's a standard that's been
put out by Microsoft that yeah so this
is a good little graphic you might have
this problem where you have a bunch of
languages and you have a bunch of
clients like editors that you want to
teach about these languages and you kind
of have like this full graph complete
graph problem that you I mean that's a
lot all of those arrows that present
represent lots of work and so with
language server protocol you have a
standard way for the two servers and
clients to talk to each other so that
you just do the you know linear thing
and you don't have to complete be
completely reinventing the wheel each
time and so I've also created a language
server protocol Pacolet to be able to
treat the Wolfram language as a language
server so that oh did I oh yeah I'm
supposed to actually like show it now so
in sublime I may have already yea gotten
ahead of myself when I jumped here
before you might have seen this in
coloring hovering right there
it might catch it I can't see if it
catches it or not I'm gonna go over here
where the other where the span is span
is at the end of the line and it show it
shows you that you you know you that the
same problem I was showing before
basically and so I have this like other
little demo dot M file with the similar
things to show you know both branches
are the same unexpect you know and so
other things too where you may have
simply just forgotten to write Q that's
probably supposed to be integer Q we all
miss a character here and there I mean
it happens so let's just make it easy to
fix so we should do that extra commas
well I should I think I need to save in
between each thing yeah yeah and so you
know we can just go through and just you
know fix these problems that should be
easy to find there now it's now it's
good I mean it's not none of this codes
doing anything but so this is an
interesting example because you probably
did not mean to write that or maybe you
did it's actually hard to tell because
the precedence of question is higher
than you might think it is and so the
way I'm selecting is actually how the
things bind first and so if that's what
you meant great you have that option
let's just make it unambiguous and let's
let's just wrap parentheses around it
and just make you know be be completely
safe about the whole thing however when
it's function you super probably didn't
mean that applied to X and so that's
treated a little bit more severely as an
error and you just have the one option
of you know wrapping around there so so
sublime text is a really popular editor
you get so sorry I'm sorry
oh yeah well so the whole thing is an
implicit multiplication that's at top
level and it's just saying like why do
you have like why are you doing times
like at top level yeah that that's all
if it was buried somewhere implicit
times completely fine they note under
things yeah yeah that that's all and I
don't know what the fix is because did
you mean this or did you know you can't
say insert star because you're missing
an equal sign so not everything's going
to have a suggestion but but a lot of
things are so I'm gonna undo all of that
and then go to visual studio code and
show the exact same thing yep it's not
wrong but I mean you super probably
meant to have it just be a single
semicolon ya know it's like like if it's
the literally the last thing on the line
yeah so yeah yeah yeah yeah so but like
don't but dick just but don't do that
either like well yeah so you when you
say for readability reasons do you mean
to make it more readable or to make it
less readable like yeah just like
readability but and so not everyone uses
sublime well let's jump over to visual
studio code hey look all of the exact
same functionality is here we can make
the same changes that we want you know
we that we made before it's really up to
you which client you want to use eclipse
Adam all of these can be down the pipe
coming down the pipe sublime and Visual
Studio code we're just the easiest ones
for me to do but any any any any client
any editor that supports language server
protocol is a you know using it that
becomes a client
LSB can now just know about Wolfram
language semantically instead of just
you know you might have just had the
syntax colouring syntax highlighting
before which is not in valley not you
know it's not useless but it's not I
mean you know it just stops there it
doesn't do it doesn't go very much
further than that so let's bring some
semantics in and let you use the editor
that you want to use as a developer to
you know to do the work you want to do
so I'm gonna make one last change
because that's the other thing you
probably didn't mean the underscore you
probably meant to say true there so yeah
just all of these other examples so yeah
so that's sublime in Visual Studio code
well it's not going to replace the
workbench plugin does so much more right
now you know like there's actual
debugging and there's actual running the
tests and it's right you know very
specific I mean I mean it would be like
this isn't a panacea by like any means
but but I mean this is doing stuff yeah
yeah well yeah I mean if that's the only
yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah definitely
you could also bring in an LSP plugin
into eclipse with the workbench and just
combine the two like they're
complementary because this is doing
stuff that the workbench isn't caching
and so just let's let's you know throw
everything that all the analyzers you
have at the same editor the same file
that you have open because you know why
not so future ideas if you have any lint
patterns that I can throw in there let
me know I'm going to be adding more
semantics to the checker because right
now it's basically working at the
expression level and you know we have
like functions and packages and like
bigger units of code that we need to
work with in the front end actually I
should magnify I don't know if people
can see
but you can see so in the future
that's hilarious squiggly lines like
actually coloring the the errors that
you have like in your input cell and
that you know like I was just saying
more LSP clients and then also it's
interesting for Microsoft from the same
people as LSP there's a debug adapter
protocol for editors and IDs that have
debugging capabilities for you to be
able to have a system of communication
for you know setting breakpoints and
stepping through code and things so if
you wanted to like use visuals to stay
in visual studio code for being able to
still debug things at Wolfram language
code you should be able to so that's not
in this demonstration right now but will
be coming down the pipe so I think this
is exciting right now and I hope you all
have a lot of suggestions and I hope to
be able to help with all of your code in
the future with all of this so thank you
you